♪ ♪
>> Jeanine: IT IS TIME NOW FOR
"ONE MORE THING," AND DANA GOES
FIRST.
>> Dana: OKAY I HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT AND A
GREAT ANNOUNCEMENT.
BOX CORPORATION HAS DONATED A
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE AMERICAN
RED CROSS TO SUPPORT ITS EFFORTS
IN SUPPORTING HURRICANE IAN
RELIEF.
THE RED CROSS IS ON THE GROUND
PROVIDING AID AND RESOURCES,
INCLUDING SHELTER, MEALS,
MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND MORE FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
THE STORM.
FOX NEWS' DOUBLE MATCHING
EMPLOYEE DONATIONS TO RED CROSS
HURRICANE RELIEF EFFORTS,
INCLUDING IAN AND FIONA APPEARED
OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH OUR TAMPA
AND ORLANDO STATION TEAM.
THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH A LOT.
OTHER FOXY PLAYS IN THE AREAS
AND EVERYONE AFFECTED BY THE
STORM.
THANK YOU TO OUR FOX TV STATION
TEAMS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
COVERING THESE DISASTERS.
OR HOW VIEWERS HELP, IF YOU'D
LIKE TO JOIN, VISIT THIS
WEBSITE, RedCross.org/FOX
FORWARD.
WE WILL HAVE IT ON THE SCREEN
FOR YOU.
JOIN FOX NEWS IN SUPPORTING THE
RED CROSS RELIEF EFFORT AND